1 les vendanges ont commencé un peu
partout en france mais dans la région du
fronton près de toulouse
elles se font quasiment de nuit en fait
c'est bien meilleur pour le vin plus le
raisin et ferait plus le nectar sera bon
cette technique est apparue il ya
quelques années déjà en france antoine
gaveau olivier copin drôle de ballet
lumineux en pleine nuit dans les vignes
de fronton ici pas de repos pour les
grappes de raisin il est 5 heures du
matin et déjà la machine les réveils
pour les croquer entre les mâchoires la
négrette raisin typiques de cette région
de toulouse
il se transformera bientôt en rose et un
vin comme chacun sait servir frais mais
a récolté aussi au petit matin ou en fin
de nuit
le raisin est bien frais naturellement
et c'est là où tout les arômes ou j3
s'exprime s'exprime le mieux pour le
vinificateur après en cube vérification
quelques minutes plus tard offrait du
directeur de la case la vendange
nocturne permet de faire un meilleur vin
voyez il fait 18 degrés et on va pouvoir
vérifier dans les meilleures conditions
la chaîne du prêt à en publier mais
étant respectés de la vigne jusqu'à la
cave
autre conséquence plus besoin de
reproduire le raisin pendant des heures
dans ces grandes cuves un effet vingt
jeunes hui égal à économie d'énergie
puisse moins de calories pour réfrigérer
le raisin donc économie d'argent à la
clé pour la cave et pour les vignerons
c'est évident - d'oxydation des
économies au final une teinte plus pâle
recherchés par les consommateurs
affrontons les vendanges de nuit sont
adoptés alors au petit matin les vignes
se repose un peu
en attendant le coucher du soleil